i don't know if we should get into anime
i watched an anime
i forgot we're an anime podcast
what did you watch
squid game
i watched
aka yeah i watched
high rise invasion what the [ __ ] is that
exactly what the [ __ ] is that i watched
high rise invasion on netflix is that uh
is that an actual anime i said look it
up the google is it's got a japanese
name um
high-rise invasion
what's the manga called in japanese
when did this get released
what is it
i've never heard of this anime before so
yeah so so what happened was that i was
like i was like i told myself i'm gonna
watch the first anime i see on netflix
why what the [ __ ] is this i've never
seen this and so i watched it right and
and uh i was pleasantly surprised i
quite enjoyed it really it wasn't it
wasn't amazing but it was it was good
fun
on imdb yeah that's and so when i when i
when i started watching it was the it
felt like the most 6.6 show
it was just good i had a fun time good
fun time it was very interesting and
stupid at times and dumb but but
interesting
you should guys should uh check it out
just to explain the plot to you please
go go on sure whoa connor explains it
this is usually the most scuffed plot
explanation of
any animation
all right so this main character forgot
her name ready wakes up on the top of a
high-rise building and you you can you
can't
go down the stairs of the high-rise you
can only cross like wooden bridges to
get to other high-rise buildings right
right and there's these dudes that are
wearing these masks that are like budget
um anonymous looking masks yeah smiley
masks and they're trying to kill you
yeah and and they're trying to they're
they're not trying to kill you they're
trying to get you to jump off the
building by making you have such despair
but that goes out the window within like
10 seconds and they're starting to kill
you right so it's one of those things
it's one of those things where they
build it up to be like a really big plot
point they're like they want to make you
feel despair and jump yourself and then
immediately they just come up to you
they're like you jump off paris
and they're like
these masks people just start killing
everyone and then it was like wait so
that wasn't that wasn't important
but then
that and then these
masks are like controlling people and
we're trying to find out what's going on
and there's some other
uh they're all issac so it's all all
these characters
all these characters why didn't you say
so earlier you can stop talking now all
these characters come from a different
world and they wake up on high-rise
buildings and have to go from different
high-rise and there's like masks that
control them and it's kind of [ __ ] but
it's it was it was interesting enough i
had a fun time i i you know what it was
nice watching a show and not caring if
it was going to be good or bad yeah i
enjoyed it and the dub was very good
very good
dichotomy because i i think like this
was this was the longest stretch where i
went not watching an anime at all damn
and uh actually picked up a jrpg that's
uh i like got [ __ ]
yeah is it was it good it was [ __ ]
amazing man why did you have to say that
now i have to get it it's it's like it's
it's the first time i played a jrpg and
like i'm just like and actually
completed it oh no i like i like i like
not only i've not only completed it i
think i'm like close to 100 percent of
it as well my god like it's the only
[ __ ] jrpg where i i cared about it so
much and i didn't want the journey to
end that i 100
the [ __ ] fishing mini game okay i
caught it that's how you know i caught
every fish in this game so i could see
every skit that there was available
in the game okay
huh how many hours have you put in this
game uh at the moment about 80 hours
so like for jrpg length that's actually
no that's not too bad that's not too bad
it's like you can you're specifically
for a hundred percent run that's not
like that's pretty short we're talking
80 hours in like the past two weeks
right yeah
i mean what else was he gonna do
uh i mean like one thing that really
surprised me is that it really got me to
care about
game mechanics i'm just like i i'm here
for the story and characters yeah and
then i just got really absolutely fans
found out that games games can be good
and then i just got really absorbed into
the combat system of this game and i'm
just like how did you trick my how did
you trick my non-gamer brain into caring
about this [ __ ] right because because
like i've played so many tales games and
the reason i go to tales was because it
had like a real-time combat system yeah
and that was i played uh brazilian and i
didn't like zarya
yeah yeah and that was in the time where
i only really got into tales games
because
every other jrpg was turned back comb uh
turn-based combat with random encounters
and tells us like no no no no how about
you have a real-time battle system with
enemies that you can see when you get
into a battle right and then that kind
of like as time goes on that became more
normalized in a lot of jrpgs like you
know you see the modern final fantasy
and it's basically just an it's an
action rpg with some turn-based systems
implemented into it and so for the
longest time i still play tails games
but they weren't they didn't grab me as
much as say back in the old school days
where this was the only type of jrpg
there was that had this type of system
and so i i like my love for the tail
series had like waned a bit
so when i got tales of a rise i only got
it because people were just like yeah
it's a new tales game and i'm like i'm a
tales fan maybe i'll just play this like
yeah i'm i'm a tales fan
gonna ignore that for a second i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm glad you said it before i
did
you kept saying tails and i just kept
thinking i was in my head i was i was
just imagining [ __ ]
so like i'm a big tales
like if i wasn't in quarantine i
wouldn't have played it and then on the
first day i just like i played it for
like a good 10 hours and i was like oh
no
oh no i'm invested
if there's one thing you don't want to
be invested in it's a jrpg because you
just have to basically write off like
two three weeks of your life if that
happens pretty much and it was like it's
been such a long time where you know
you know like when you're so absorbed
into a game that every waking moment
you're not playing the game you you're
either playing the game or you're
thinking about playing the game i miss
that feeling yeah yeah and it was it was
[ __ ] great and uh the combat system
in this is like closer to something like
devil may cry than it is like previously
like you can you can you can do like
[ __ ] ridiculous amounts of combos in
this game right can i can i go for about
the game mechanics do you care about the
game mechanics at all um sure i mean
it's better than you talking about error
game
i'd love to hear how you like it okay so
most tales games i played before it's
just like [ __ ] button mashing like
you press yeah that's what i didn't like
about it yeah the last time i played it
yeah and you can get through a lot of
this game through just button mashing
and then like it there's there's this
really weird difficulty curve where the
later part parts of the game you like
before in every tales games you can just
get away with like tapping one button
tapping special attack anything like
that but then they've built they've
layered so many different systems onto
this combat system from like previous
tales games that you can you you realize
you can just start layering [ __ ] over
like things over things everything's
everything so they introduce you to you
like you only have you can only do a
certain amount of moves for before your
character goes back into a rest state
right so you can you can only do like
three basic attacks and enough enough
basic enough special attacks before your
meter runs dry but then if you juggle
the enemy you add more basic attacks on
on top of that right
and then on top of that you have
group you have group attacks as well
where people in your party can also join
in on an attack and then what i didn't
realize is that tails added this system
where you can switch to another person
mid like like mid battle so you don't
have to pause the game to switch to
another character you can literally it's
a tap of one button you can switch to
another person so you basically you can
basically chain combos end combo with
one person then switch to like do a
special attack with another person
switch to that person and so the system
awards
awards people who are able to change
really good combos because if you get
your combo meter long enough then you
can do basically a finishing attack yeah
right it looks kind of like gentian a
little bit
yeah that's that's the thing it's
basically like it did it was a lot like
engine except having except not having
just one person but having four people
yeah
that your chain when you're playing
against how much yeah that you've
changed
yeah but there's a lot it's like way
more in depth than genji i would say it
is it does have
some similarities to the genshin combat
system but it's like way more in depth
and you can
get combos that are like way longer than
genji you get like 100 hit combos
sometimes the only thing that i found
really funny and
i don't know if this is the whole game
but i was watching someone stream it on
twitch and they were fighting this
dragon
and during this fight every single
character was saying their voice lines
at every single point yeah and i was
like what the [ __ ] is this i can't hear
anything everyone is just screaming in
their own attacks yeah is that is that
happening all the time
yeah pretty much that's pretty standard
for a job but i couldn't hear anything i
couldn't hear what anyone was saying
because everyone was shouting their
attacks i was like what is this i mean
it's the same with like uh like
xenoblade as well right like when you're
when you're fighting that [ __ ] i can't
watch because that's
it xenoblade annoys me watching
xenoblade because i'm just hearing
everything
at the same time
don't you like that no i can't because i
can't hear what everyone's saying it's
just noise you don't have to hear what
they're saying i i i can't if i wanted
to i can't hear it it's not it's not
like they're giving like important
information i just wish that it was like
i don't know when i was watching
from a viewing experience it was very
annoying at least right from a gaming
news probably he didn't give a [ __ ]
i think i think
i think if you're watching it yeah as a
viewer it might get a little bit
annoying because that's the only thing
you're focusing on yeah but again it's
not like they're gonna be like they're
gonna drop like huge narrative plot
points as they're going
i'm your dad
i know i was just like this is too loud
shut up
because like on top of that as well
sometimes uh sometimes the characters
will have conversations with each other
i mean there's there is a lot of things
going on i love that i love that about
tales yeah and this kind of campaign
that's that's the anime side that i live
for you know there's something super
campy about it that i love it's like one
person is like being like hey that was a
good shot and the other one's like ah
he's like all right you're not listening
it's pretty cool though it's actually
like a little better uh combat system
than before yeah i don't trust people
who prefer um turn-based combat over
that i'm just like what's wrong with you
who hurt you i mean
[Laughter]
i didn't say anything
why who is it who is it who
except for persona we haven't figured
out a way to make it fun so we keep
using the same shitty thing because we
know it sort of works but like no one's
like right yeah
i don't like turn-based combat i don't
know i'm just used to it so much to the
point where i like but that's the thing
though i think that's that's that's why
people people
if you didn't grow up with it it's
[ __ ] annoying yeah and i i think it's
just because it's one of the it's a
thing that we haven't figured out a
better way and i still feel that some
games the whole real-time combat in the
way is still kind of jank at times yeah
it sounds like it's it's good it's
really good i think they finally figured
out a little bit yeah it's it's really
good because because they teach you the
basics and then they don't teach you all
these like more advanced techniques that
you can do to like basically extend your
extend your combos and like make
flashier moves but they give you
gameplay incentives like i said like if
you get a combo for long enough without
stopping it
then you can do a finishing move on an
enemy and like when they're when they're
high health it's harder than when
they're low health so they come with me
to build up faster when they're low
health so like when when you sometimes
you start off a battle
and depending on how well you can get
your combo off because when when you
kill one enemy with a finishing move
that makes it easier to do the next
enemy and the next enemy it's kind of
like a domino effect right so you can
you can depending on your the difficulty
if you start off a battle well you can
clear the enemy so fast or you'll you
can like get ko'd really easily
depending on like how well you start off
your how are you starting for your
attacks on your combos which is just
which is just something that i never
experienced before in a tales game
because tales was always i'm playing
because i like it and it's anime and
it's jr story and then the combat the
combats here just is just to
like forget making me forget about the
fact that i just hate grinding and
combats and like yeah i don't like
riding and turn-based battles but this
one was just it's legit good game it's
i can see why it's like the closest
thing tails has got to like a mainstream
release
because it is a legit good game that i
think a lot of people who don't even
like jrpgs would like um
so yeah
i've been tempted ever since they
announced that i'm just like i can't do
it to myself
i have so many [ __ ] jrpgs lined up
that i still need to play i still
haven't played the [ __ ] like uh near
replicant i was like the wrong place
i bought that on steam and it's just
been sitting there i'm just like i'll
get to it
that's that's steam that's how it is
i'll get to it eventually and then
they're like okay there's five more
jrpgs i bought sega uh bass fish not
bass bass [ __ ]
it's like a bass fishing and i never
bought it i never played
why
why not god
because
fishing i actually think we should do a
trash taste special we do high score on
sega fishing
look at that game look at that can we
just go real fishing i'd rather go i'll
probably just go real fishy and then
please i also really want to play the
new [ __ ] nickelodeon fighting game
they actually made it into like a
serious like fighter yeah yeah and
apparently someone's already figured out
that some characters are just [ __ ] of
course i believe we're gonna be getting
patch notes for days and tier lists yeah
spongebob is asked here patrick is
detailed spongebob bottom two behind
bottom tiers
oh my god